[Music]
cartoon TV show fans have always wanted
to know more about the creation of their
favorite characters how do we know what
fan theories may be true and which are
completely made-up make sure to wash
until the end of the video to find out
our number one misconception about the
iconic Bugs Bunny if you like learning
about fan theories as much as we do make
sure to subscribe to the thing and give
this video a big thumbs up today we're
going over the 10 biggest misconceptions
about popular cartoon TV shows the Ninja
Turtles bandana colors from comic strip
and animated TV show to toy figures and
live action movie the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles have been a part of our
lives since 1984 the quirky characters
Leonardo Raphael Donatello and
Michelangelo were not always the
light-hearted goofy heroes we know today
originating from a black-and-white comic
book the characters bandanas were not
always their signature colors in fact
they used to all have red masks the need
to associate a bandana color to
distinguish between each Ninja Turtle
was a result from a marketing strategy
to develop a cartoon series and action
figures to appeal to a younger audience
the original comic was considered to be
pg-13 with occasional swear words and
more violence in fact the original
distinguishing factor between each
character was their individual choice of
weapons this also would not have been
appropriate for a younger audience even
some of the characters had to change as
a result of the shift in audience in the
comics the Ninja Turtles had an ally
vigilante Casey Jones adorned with a
hockey mask Casey Jones would fight
against low-level criminals going so far
as beating them with baseball bats this
is a significantly darker aspect of the
cartoon TV show we know and love instead
of an ally vigilante
we have shredder a villain we really do
love to hate ultimately the choice to
trade in swear words and weapons for
colored bandanas and pizza was a good
one as TMNT continues to be a cartoon TV
show for the ages Seth MacFarlane's
claim to fame is Family Guy now on
Netflix fan can watch their favorite
Family Guy episodes over and over
enjoying the spot-on entertaining
satirical humor that writer creator and
actor Seth MacFarlane is known for
although many would argue that
McFarland's claimed
with his hilarious stories about main
character Peter Griffin and his family
he had experience working on another
popular cartoon TV show before Family
Guy Dexter's Laboratory was a show about
a temperamental small-sized scientist
and his meddling tall blonde sister
Dexter's elaborate schemes made him a
lovable yet misguided character who
always got himself in and out of
ridiculous situations although only
having written four episodes of the show
MacFarlane had a taste of writing for a
successful cartoon show before he had
started working on Family Guy his
following success with Ted Ted 2 and 1
million ways to die in the West
continues to display McFarland's
unparalleled writing scooby-doo's
ability to speak English scooby-doo is a
timeless series that focuses on a group
of friends and a talking dog solving
mysteries and catching masked criminals
however entertaining this show and the
ensuing live-action movie are
scooby-doo's unexplained ability to
speak English has been questioned by
fans this has resulted in an extremely
elaborate fan theory that has been so
well thought out it could even be
convincing
this theory supposes that the reason for
the dog's linguistic abilities is
because he was a Soviet experiment
scooby-doo where are you was the show's
first episode in 1969 just after the
American and Russian space race because
Russians first sent dogs into outer
space before risking humans the theory
claims that in the scooby-doo universe
Russian scientists went a step forward
in creating a program that bred dogs to
be capable of human thought and ability
to speak scooby-doo is theorized to have
created an intimate bond with one of the
scientists as a puppy and was thereby
granted the opportunity to escape this
fan theory doesn't hold up in the real
world but is a well-crafted argument for
a show that was created during the Cold
War
plus if we're going to try to speculate
about a mysterious misconception it
might as well be scooby-doo a show that
revolves around the premise of solving
mysteries Dexter's Lab inspired Big Bang
Theory in 2008 The Big Bang Theory
released their complete season 2 on the
front of the box was an image that was
an exact replica of Dexter's Laboratory
each of the series characters matched in
an identical pose this began an Internet
wave of speculation regarding the use of
this image for the popular TV comedy
series was the Big Bang Theory inspired
by our beloved Dexter the
insinuate an unhealthy sibling
relationship not at all
creator of the image Wickfield claims
that the likeness between photos was
simply based on physical characteristics
and personality traits
although Penny and Leonard are depicted
as Dexter and Dee Dee this was simply a
representation of their role on the show
and the fact that both Dee Dee and Penny
are the only blonde females on each show
aside from that the only other
comparison seems to be based on the fact
that both shows are based on an interest
in science although a history of
inspiration from Dexter's Laboratory
would have been a fascinating story
about the inspiration for the sitcom it
seems to simply be a case of fantastic
artwork that the internet can't get
enough of nevertheless this piece of
artwork has been the foundation of fan
fiction and theories galore it really
does seem to be true that pictures can
be worth a thousand words whether those
words are true or not that's always up
for debate and in this case is proven to
certainly be a misconception spongebob
squarepants is a result of nuclear
testing next on the list is a cartoon TV
show that continues to be popular since
it first aired in 1999 fans love the
wacky stories of spongebob a sponge and
his friends among which include patrick
the starfish sandy the squirrel
Squidward the octopus and mr. Krabs
the businessman crab this world in
bikini bottom is a peculiar one and fans
have been trying to determine where
these strange yet lovable characters
might have come from the most popular
fan theory out there is that Bikini
Bottom is actually based on Bikini Atoll
a u.s. nuclear testing site in 1946 at
the time one particular bomb was called
Baker and it was led off underwater is
the name of the nuclear site and the
setting of Spongebob Squarepants simply
a coincidence or does it justify the
underwater creatures ability to speak
and function as a town actor and voice
of Spongebob Tom Kenny has responded to
the speculation regarding the show's
origin story kenny dismisses the theory
stating that the Bikini Atoll nuclear
testing as an explanation for the
characters mutations is simply a
misconception
instead he clarifies that the world of
Bikini Bottom is like another planet
altogether where the laws that govern
our world are no longer applicable a
reference to historical phenomena would
be out of place as SpongeBob's success
is partly a result of the lack of
interaction with pop culture never
referencing events from outside of
show Kenny believes that this
contributes to the show's long lasting
popularity as it never becomes
irrelevant regardless of where some of
TV's favorite characters come from we're
just happy they can continue to exist on
our screens Lady Rainicorn slang guack
adventure time has a unique goofy
fantasy like feel that we can't get
enough of it may be a surprise to hear
that the voice actor responsible for
Lady Rainicorn also voices [ __ ] s
character and as a storyboard artist for
the show there has been a lot of
questions regarding what language Lady
Rainicorn speaks some even claiming it's
Japanese
in fact the characters voice actor Niki
yang grew up in the United States but
was born in Korea as her first voice
acting job yang decided to voice the
character in Korean the rumor that Lady
Rainicorn is speaking Japanese is simply
a misconception regardless of any
language barrier audiences still love
Lady Rainicorn as much as any other
character on the show this is due to the
show's ability to give the characters
issues and relationships that are easy
for audiences to relate to making it a
show as successful among kids as it is
with teens and adults yang has even
commented in interviews about the impact
Lady Rainicorn has made on Korean
American kids who sent her messages and
emails about how much they enjoy the
character on top of speaking a foreign
language Lady Rainicorn was also the
first pregnant unicorn on TV we love
Adventure Time for its humor that can be
appreciated on so many levels and at so
many ages misconceptions are common for
characters new and old wait until you
hear our number one misconception about
Bugs Bunny
Rugrats voices Believe It or Not the
next cartoon TV show on our list was
inspired by asking a simple question if
babies could talk what would they say
Rugrats took fans by storm as we loved
having the chance to get to see how
babies might view the world the show
appealed to children and parents who
enjoyed the change in perspective about
what it's like to learn about the world
you're growing up in the babies Tommy
Chuckie dill the twins and Angelica
entertained multiple generations of
viewers their voices brought a baby's
thoughts to life but it may be
surprising to learn that all of the
babies voices were produced by women
even though four of the main characters
were boys it is women responsible for
their distinct voices Christine
Cavanaugh the voice of Chuckie Finster
was also the voice actress for Dexter in
Esther's Laboratory and babe the talking
pig these women were very dedicated to
the show and their characters Elizabeth
Daly the voice of Tommy pickles
even continued to record while she was
in labor through brilliant acting
writing and animation we would never
have guessed that the voices of the
characters we loved was produced by
another other than children
Tigger's voice since 1968 fans have
known and loved the voices and endearing
personalities of the cast of Winnie the
Pooh Winnie the Pooh in the blustery day
was even awarded an Academy Award for
best animated short film among most
recognizable voices is Paul Winchell the
voice behind the bouncing upbeat Tigger
Winchell who has since passed away
was one of the most iconic voices on
television using his British wife for
the inspiration of Tigers catchphrase
TTFN Tata for now
Winchell was used to performing and
entertaining a young audience as a
ventriloquist whose dummies are now
displayed at the Smithsonian Institution
in Washington on top of his success as
an actor and entertainer Winchell was
also an inventor and was most known for
his invention of an early artificial
heart he built in 1963 and then donated
to the University of Utah for research
among his 30 patents Winchell has also
invented a disposable razor and a
flameless cigarette lighter it's amazing
that a lispy voice and contagious laugh
we recognize as Tigger is also the
inventor of so many important products
and devices dying at the age of 82 in
2005 Winchell's voice will continue to
live on through one of the most
memorable cartoons of all time evil
Morty and Rick's audience this next
entry on our list is probably the least
kid-friendly cartoon TV show the lack of
appeal to a young audience however has
not prevented Rick and Morty from
becoming extremely popular fan theories
and fan fiction typically indicate
massive interest in the storyline origin
and hidden implications of TV shows Rick
and Morty is no exception with the evil
Morty theory that we'll explore today
fans first discovered the existence of
evil morty adorned with an eyepatch in
the tenth episode of season one close
Rick counters of the Rick kind evil
Morty appeared as a member of the evil
Rick & Morty team who sought to
eradicate Rick's from other dimensions
the most shocking part of the episode
was that evil Rick had been controlled
by evil Morty's transmitter located
beneath his eyepatch the origin story of
evil Morty starts to get
very complicated as it's an
interdimensional explanation
substantiated by the photograph of Rick
holding baby Morty in episode 2 this
suggests that the Morty we know who has
returned after 20 years although he's
only 14 is not the same Morty in the
photo making it possible that there is a
different evil Morty
though this well-thought-out theory
might have some ground the whole premise
of the show is its unpredictability so
trying to predict the outcome of its
characters is futile nevertheless trying
to wrestle with the show's use of
quantum physics while speculating about
its characters is definitely one of the
reasons why Rick and Morty continues to
be so popular is Bugs Bunny a rabbit or
a hare Bugs Bunny has been a family name
since the 1940s making him not only
number one on our list but also the
oldest this characters popularity was
not solely based on his appeal to
children he was also extremely popular
during World War two
even named the army mascot and starting
countless propaganda cartoons known for
his catchphrase what's up doc and his
mischievous ways of outrunning his
hunter Elmer Fudd this so-called bunny
may not be what he appears to be the
first Bugs Bunny episode was actually
called a wild hare prompting us to
question if bugs is a bunny or a hare
based on his physical characteristics
it seems that bugs isn't actually a
bunny just like hares bugs has long hind
legs long ears and is a grayish color
bunnies on the other hand or a brown
color have shorter legs and smaller ears
further adding to the fact that bugs is
really a hair is the fact that hairs
like our bugs do not stay with their
family while bunnies do convinced that
bugs has the wrong name well this could
be another misconception unlike bugs who
burrows underground like bunnies do
hairs live exclusively above-ground
the only way we could clear the
confusion is by taking a DNA test to
determine if bugs has 48 chromosomes
like a hair or 44 chromosomes like a
rabbit unfortunately this isn't possible
as Bugs Bunny lives in our minds and our
hearts in the end does it really matter
if bugs is a bunny or a hare let us know
what you think in the comments below
well that's it for the 10 biggest
misconceptions about popular cartoon TV
shows if you want to see more stories
like this make sure to watch 10
ridiculous examples of cartoon logic
that will make you facepalm thanks for
watching
[Music]